like what do you mean it's too late i
see i should have started at seven you
should have start talking
and making sure these things they
understand slowly these things
because they're already exposed to it by
the age of seven i'll give you an
example
living in the western countries the
schools are already exposing them
at the age of seven eight and so on it's
in the curriculum
there's been some crazy attempts from
some of the scandinavian countries
to you know do things with children
experiments and
in the curriculum cartoons you name it
so
yeah it's going to be there it's going
to be there so the more you kind of try
to turn a blind eye and be over pious
and
you know think this is taboo and we
cannot talk about it
you know it's wrong and so on okay
fine but they're still gonna get it
they're still gonna get it
if the prophet saw sallam was open
and the quran talks about it the sunnah
talks about it
sahabas were very young were learning
these things
um the non-muslim society is talking
about it
yet the muslim community is saying
no no no no i don't think i want to talk
about this this is very shameful
my father didn't do this to me so i
cannot do this to my son
okay but still it will happen
and they will get the wrong information
i don't take anything personal i don't
take anything really that serious
now of course if the person touches me
if they do something if they
transgress then you already know what's
going to happen but i'm just saying like
you have to invest your energy into
something
or else your energy is going to be going
into all these different things
i speak from experience because i used
to get triggered a lot
i used to take things very seriously i
used to get angry at
every little thing so
try these things out for yourself and
see how it works
the three muslims podcast i'm your host
rami with fayad and angel and again we
have
with us brother gabriel romani
so this is the second episode in the
intimacy series that we started if you
did not watch episode 1 go back and
watch that before
this one because that one is very very
crucial so if you have not seen that
make sure you check it out first
so we're going to get right into this
insha allah with some questions for
brother gabriel insha allah
where do we start with our kids right
how do we how do we
teach them about intimacy and where do
we start with them
so the issue of i guess we can call it
sexual education when it comes to
to children right um what's the right
age a lot of parents ask
and so on and i believe that
it is obviously something that should be
done in the right time and by the right
person so
you have boys the father should take
care of the boys
you have girls the mother should take
care of the girls you know it's just
more appropriate
and i think the children also
find that that is is more they can
connect better you know the guy sort of
to the father and the
the girls to the mother um the timing
specifically obviously living in today's
society there's just so much around like
they're being bombarded with this kind
of information
i've looked recently into some of the
curriculums
in the uk i believe they were aiming to
introduce this
to like grade one and grade two children
to talk about seven years old right to
talk about
intimacy and and so on there are already
literature and books that are available
for children that deal with for example
um you know homosexuality and stuff like
that because that's that community is
pushing really hard they're being very
aggressive
so you could say pretty much that by the
age of seven eight nine
the children are already exposed to that
if they go to public school
um that that the chances of them being
exposed to this increase
with children coming from home you
cannot control what they see
what they hear at home and what they do
and they share it uh my mom for example
is still a teacher
and she teaches in the catholic district
in canada
and um you know she tells me sometimes
some of the kids men they're like they
you know the little ones they say some
weird stuff you know and then should be
like would you hear that i'm like
my dad said it you know or something
like that right my mom said
and that is something like you know
alarming that at that
young age they are exposed to these kind
of things
and they hear these kind of things so
the muslim parent now
is faced with protecting their child and
okay so how should i approach this issue
how should i
talk to them how should i explain to
them
right how should i get them excited
about the prospect of getting married at
some point
right you know children will come home
and be like mommy
how are babies done or made you know or
something like that right they say stuff
like that like that is exactly what they
say
and uh it has to be answered if you're
gonna you know what what would the
usually the parent would be like oh you
know this is not something you should be
talking about why are you talking about
this
you know shame on you and so on and then
we shame them
then they go somewhere or they find an
avenue because now curiosity has been
you know turned on so now they go and
look for a place to
find their answer right and not just
that they're gonna lose
they're going to lose trust in you that
if they have a serious issue or a
serious question you will dismiss them
and that is one of the greatest mistakes
that parents do they dismiss their
children
when they come up with these kind of
questions so of course you're not going
to give him a full-fledged
anatomical correct you know discourse on
intimacy but you can say you know that
mommy met daddy they got married
and they loved each other and they had
you you know
and that's something you know that is
appropriate for someone who's younger
and then you know slowly you can explain
because
they themselves start asking questions
about their own
body parts their private parts why do i
have this
why you know my sister doesn't have it
they do see each other naked sometimes
you know and when they're little they
take about
and this is normal they will say things
like that
you know why this why that whatever you
know and then
they uh they you know so you explain to
them that you're a boy
she's a girl and this is this and this
is that
so don't feel shy or dismiss them answer
their question
so i would say it happens naturally
i don't think there's any parent that
did not get these kind of questions
it just naturally happens the problem is
for those who dismiss it and then they
break the trust of the children
and then the children will not come back
and ask these and it becomes
a scar trauma that my my father my
mother dismissed me or shamed me
especially muslim countries the shaming
thing happens a lot
where it's like hey when it's bad and
how dare you talk like that and you know
maybe get slapped and whatnot
and then they do not come back to this
topic they will take it out with someone
else
so i would say that
parents have to be very vigilant to
understand the development of their
children
as a parent if you're just turning a
blind eye
to the development of your children
their inquiries their
you know them being inquisitive on this
subject
you will blink and you will wake up in a
mess you'll just blink and then it'll be
too late
and then you come to the sheikh the
imams and the counselors you know they
come to us and they're like
please save my child i'm like what's the
problem well he's like this and like
that and committed zinna and
i'm like how old is he 14. i said it's
too late
now you want to talk to them about
intimacy they already committed zinna
but i thought he's just my little boy i
never expected that
i tell you what happened i had one
teacher
i'm not going to name the school and but
i was working in a country in a muslim
country
it's not here it's not now it's quite
some years back
and at that time i was yeah i was the
principal there
and we had an incident in grade 3
grade 3 bro okay so grade three
and this is an all girls school
okay grade three is nine year old
and subhanallah and these girls became
intimate with each other
you know and it became like an epidemic
the whole class pretty much
you know it it went crazy and
till it reached one girl whose family
taught
her that this is this and this is that
and this is wrong
so she's the one who reported imagining
she's the one who basically reported it
and you know what the teacher i had to
like let her go
because she was denying she's like no i
i i could never imagine this could
happen i don't believe it
and i said sister you better believe it
no i cannot believe in our culture this
is not acceptable
this doesn't happen i think they're just
you know talking
and i was like yeah allah you know i got
so upset
because i said we are suffering there's
a there's an
epidemic in this class and look what it
led to
and because the teacher was closing
their eyes they didn't realize why are
four or five girls going to the bathroom
together at the same time
all the time every day you know they
didn't raise they know because no no
this can never happen no no our children
can never do these things
wake up wake up i keep saying wake
up brothers and sisters so yes we have
to clean up
you know it's a big mess people need to
understand
that these things will happen if you
would close a blind eye if you don't
teach
yes you teach okay guys and when you go
for example through stories of the quran
and you talk about the story of prophet
yusuf ali sam what are you going to do
you're going to skip over the verses
of the women are you going to skip over
the verses about prophet luthem
are you going to skip over the verses of
this and that
no you cannot right we teach islamic
studies and teach it
explain to the children why this woman
wanted prophet yusuf
why this why that yes sometimes women
would chase men yes in jahlia i was like
man in the western country is like
normal you know
it's like it's not enough for a guy to
lower his gaze he's got to run away too
man you know because the girl is going
to chase him
if he's a good looking guy he's going to
be chased
so it's not people need to talk to
understand how do you connect that to
surah yusuf
how do you connect what happened
you know to to the story of of luth
how do you connect you know these these
issues to the events
the prophet saws selling for example
and then the end right how do you the
story of if the accusation of
of aisha in surah nur
you know the the the the sharia
injunctions about
whipping and and you know the issue of
zina
how how how do you connect this how do
our children memorize the quran by the
age of eight and nine
fully and they have no clue what it says
how does allah talk you know they
memorize
in jesus and they know just about and
you know
uh you know the the ayat about horlane
for example
and they don't know what it is you know
it's there
i mean they memorize it we need to
understand islam is
clear about this yet it's it's not like
indecent in
in way it talks about there's there's a
way to do it
but parents need to need to i would say
teachers islamic schools muslim
curriculums
when they teach the quran they teach the
hadith they teach these things
has to be with guided exposure i call it
guided exposure
meaning you just don't open the
floodgates but you guidedly expose them
and tell them and teach them and
show them why do
muslims not talk about the
excitement of being married why is it
becoming so oh
you know taboo right guys should know
hey guys you're gonna get
like today subhanallah i was in the mall
today
with my son you know and he
moved away from me he took the escalator
and i just i tried to grab him by the
hand i didn't look
i almost grabbed this young girl you
know and
and i looked i was like oh so sorry you
know she was like this nice girl you
know hijab
and her mom was with her you know and i
said so you know and they realized
because they saw him and i was like oh
then they realized that okay i made a
mistake you know because i wasn't
looking i was going to grab her in my
hand just take her with me you know
so when i reached up i caught up with my
son i said bro i was going to bring you
your wife man you know i said that's
your future wife right there you know
and and he was cool about it you know
he's like because we talk about these
things you know
i've already had the talk with him he's
he's 12 right now
but by the age of like 10 9 9 something
10 i think that's the first time i
talked about you know
these things with him you know and he
was asking me stuff like what is
you know this word mean and what does
that word mean you know like some of the
slang that
you know he heard in the classroom right
uh like what is an erection and stuff
like that but he was a different word
you know
and i explained to him i said very
clearly he's like yeah it's so annoying
you know it's like when i wake up and
it's like this you know
and i was like yeah i know it's annoying
it's horrible i said but it's part of
being a man this is when you know there
being a man i said he said really
i said yeah this is one of the signs
that you know that you're being a man
you know
and like sometimes i would see him like
you know like we're in the elevator one
time i saw him you know looking at a
girl you know this
cute girl came in the elevator and he
was like looking at her you know and he
couldn't
stop staring and i said i said what's up
bro like what's going on
and he didn't realize it you know it's
just so natural you know what i mean
it was just so natural and i said what's
going on what's up i said what'd you
feel you know
he's like i don't know i didn't do
anything he didn't realize that you know
i say yeah but you were like eyeing that
girl you know i said why you think she's
cute or something
and he said yeah she was kind of cute i
was like yeah you know i said uh
this is how it is i said look you know
you have to understand you're gonna have
to lower your gaze because you're gonna
get different feelings
so i use that opportunity and that's
what i'm saying it just naturally
happens you know
like if you spend enough time with your
children
and you know them and you're open with
them
naturally there'll be certain events in
their life
where it's just going to open up the
subject you know and that's what's
called an education it's called the
teachable moment
in education this is called a teachable
moment
it is that moment where that person has
just experienced something that
contextualizes
that idea and it will drive the point
home
you know what i mean and if you lose
that moment
if you ignore that moment it might not
come back
you know it might not come back so yes i
believe naturally it happens that we
should speak about intimacy to our
children
about their development about the
feelings that they get because we know
because we've gone through it
and i also believe it should be
systematically done at a curriculum
level
where schools adopt a certain way
of connecting to the quran to the sunnah
of the prophet
to the stories of the quran and talking
about these things in a
proper respectful manner but
to rise in them the the to look forward
you know
like i believe young girls should look
forward to marriage to their wedding day
you know
today they're this gammaphobia you know
they're they're scared of marriage
right because they've been hit so much
with so many failures and divorce and
they hear this they're 10 years old and
they're experiencing this they're seeing
their parents
they're seeing the movies they're seeing
the media they're scared
i get messages from young sisters their
mothers
mothers whatever say i'm scared of
marrying my daughter's
you know has a phobia of marriage
it used to be that back in the days
girls used to dream about their wedding
dresses their wedding gowns they used to
you know just fantasize about the day
where their
prince charming will come and and take
them you know in marriage right
and right now they're they're hating it
so we're wondering why things are bad
and the guy is the same you know
you want to wish for this this is the
time you prepare for it
mentally you you aspire for it
right but if you don't if you don't have
that desire and that
you know like honestly you know like my
daughter comes to me sometimes she's
like
you know like she tells me like when are
you gonna get me married
you know like stuff like that and it's
like me and my wife are looking at like
oh my god you know
and then i'm like okay it's good
question i said it depends like what
kind of guy do you like so we open up
the discussion
and subhanallah i learned so much about
her likes and dislikes and
like i can all i can i can say that i
know what kind of guy my daughter
likes you know what i mean at this point
but i've never
i've never ever ever made it to her in
such a way that she'll feel embarrassed
about this
you know and sometimes she said like she
has a crush on this guy or something i
said look this is natural these feelings
are natural
but allah puts certain boundaries for us
so we do not
cross those boundaries so we do not
cause something wrong or
go astray but i said but alhamdulillah
you know has given us the option of
marriage
and i'm going to make a nice wedding for
you and don't worry i'll do this and
then she's so excited you know
like but i believe if i would have like
said asta for allah you know
maryam this is not good you know
shouldn't be thinking about these things
right now
she would have been pushed down and she
i would have killed her
her her hopes you know
so we need to we need to to be careful
with this
because i believe our children should be
excited
to get married they should be excited
about finally
reaching halal and intimacy you know
they're always told
and where is the halal at least to have
the dream that the haral will come one
day
even just the feeling that hey there is
light at the end of the tunnel
gives you the drive to stay you know to
protect yourself
and to you know wish that the future
comes
but if not if we're closing all the
doors we're denying
we're not talking the non-muslims are
talking they
are opening their arms they say come
come we'll take care of you don't worry
you want to express your feelings we're
here to listen to whatever you want
we're here
while the muslims are not there and this
is the reality i hear
from some of my clients saying the
muslims are not there
for me they're always judgmental allah
doesn't judge you
any on just your feelings if you can
control these are feelings that will
come to you naturally
is how you express them and whether you
act upon him that that's what leads you
to action then you get judged
but we you know a person cannot even
discuss certain things that right away
judgment is passed doors are closed the
fingers are pointed
and this over pious you know character
comes about
and people shut down and then they go to
the non-muslims and they say at least
these people don't judge me i can be
myself i can express myself i can say
you know and talk and you know
this is it is you know this is what
happens so
the time is is is at the right time it
happens naturally
schools principals teachers should make
it a point
to look for those teachable moments
should make a lesson out of it
recently i had a discussion with my
students where i said you know what guys
just close your
book okay take a piece of paper write a
question on these people but don't put
your name on it
and subhanallah the first question that
came
the first question was can i watch
porn with my husband to learn about sex
okay and you know what i said i said
okay guys if you guys don't feel
comfortable
uh you can leave right now i will answer
the question but those who don't feel
comfortable you can leave the class you
know
everyone stayed in you know to listen
can i address the question i don't care
what people are gonna say i properly
addressed the question
because these kids had genuine questions
and
the more i opened the questions the more
interesting they got and it was all
somehow related to this to show what's
in their mind
and the question that was written is not
a joke and the people are like
like this you know they're just
listening and waiting i was very
polite in the way i formulated my answer
but it is important they have these
questions
if we don't talk about it if we don't
teach them guided exposure polite
correct exposure they will take it in
the wrong way so
yes let us train our parents train our
teachers
address it okay look for the puberty
signs
start talking mothers with daughters
fathers with with sons better okay
um if your daughter comes to you as a
man
uh well i don't know there might be that
she feels a bit comfortable
maybe you might gonna have to answer
some questions as well i had to
uh sometimes you might want to say okay
go to your mom you know
that you might lose that teachable one
i'm but i think
husbands and wife have to talk and they
have to agree
that when these kind of questions come
in that they both kind of are ready to
answer them
and they don't shy away from them and um
yeah it's got to be at a systematic
level
as well now
amazing answer very in-depth masha'allah
and if only everyone had
a father like that masha'allah so many
kids young girls especially young girls
like it's that entire discussion
completely non-existent to them
it's so sad allah is so sad
so subhanallah may allah forgive us and
guide us
so let's say you have this kid and you
go through these steps
of you know answering their questions
and using the teachable moments and
teaching them properly and effectively
throughout their life and then this kid
hits an appropriate age where they can
honestly start looking towards marriage
and they can genuinely say okay i want
to get married
how would they know they're ready what
are the requirements for
for marriage for a man and for a woman
how does it differ
and how i guess how would you vet a
person as well as an important question
okay um type
i think
obviously culture and timing plays a
you know a huge role in answering this
question
however i believe that
again going back to the sunnah the
process again people say but you know
we're not writing camels today and we're
not
you know wearing swords and stuff like
that i agree
however these you know these
questions that deal with you know
transportation
or food or clothing that's a different
story we're talking here about ethics
and morals and
things that deal with with muammar and
dealings
with people and when we look at the
again the life of the process of sahabah
the culture was that they got married
early and we know the
controversy of aisha allah and her age
when she got married right so the
orientalists and the non-muslims always
bring this issue up
however we know that i shall deal with a
woman
by sharia you are a man or a woman once
once you hit puberty okay
biologically speaking also you are a man
and a woman
once you hit puberty because now you can
reproduce pretty much
once the man produces sperm and the
woman releases the egg
and she gets her period and so on she
now
can be a mother okay now when you're a
mother you're not a girl anymore you are
basically a
a woman so biologically speaking
a person can basically be ready to be
intimate and married at the age of
puberty okay
um psychologically as well
we see that's a different story
obviously uh when we look at culture
today
men and women of today boys and girls
today are not the same that they were
before
because of these stimuli the environment
that conditions
us so you find that men still in their
20s and 30s they're still playing
pokemon cards you know
in their parents basement so they don't
have a level of maturity
to be able to lead a family all right so
that's something that
we find till today so there's a lot of
variables when it comes to this but
biologically speaking as i said
and that's where the issue comes in that
men and women are biologically ready to
be intimate by the age of
13 12 sometimes 14
but they're not emotionally and
physically
intellectually financially ready so
there is
a misalignment between
those readiness so what's the problem
the problem is
exactly what we're talking about right
now so they want to be intimate they
have the need to be intimate
yet they cannot marry so means they
cannot be intimate in the
halal sense so i am a man
i am 13 years old i've just discovered
that you know i have wet dreams and i
desire women and i look around for girls
and that's what it is you know when 13
14 a lot of these boys
you know i mean i've been teaching again
in boys schools and
like wolves you know they see a woman
it's like subhanallah you know
and it's just the way it is their their
hormones are raging
okay so what can you do what are the
options okay get married but you cannot
he's not ready he doesn't have the
ability financially
his parents laugh at him in his face
when he talks about marriage even if
anyone would dare say that
they say you're just a little boy man
you know sit down
but physically they're ready to be
intimate
you understand they are ready to be
intimate physically they want to be
intimate so what's going to happen
well a few things can happen number one
that they masha allah very piously
fast and lowered their gaze and just
wait for a wet dream to take place to
release that
desire okay if it would be that easy
number two what happens is that a lot of
them start messing around they start
dating
uh you know and committing zinna all
right and this happens a lot
number three some of the boys and some
of the girls sadly
okay they do turn to each other for
uh you know this play you know thing
that they do and they have experiences
with each other and this is something
that happens
is quite popular and a lot of people
deny but it happens
boys play around with boys and girls
play around with girls no one questions
it
it happens a lot okay because
subhanallah in muslim countries
happens a lot a lot because no one
questions it
all right and i've even asked my
students about i've talked very openly
i've
researched and asked and discussed and
talked to even those people
and they said hey what can we do it's
not as bad as
zina or it's not as bad as being with a
boy or with a girl or whatever you know
so some people actually believe that it
is okay
to have those kind of experiences but
they don't understand that that's going
to condition them for later and
ganomestima
another option is of course the issue of
pornography which is very very rampant
so they are biologically they want to be
intimate but
they cannot do it in halal the doors of
halal are closed anyway even if let's
say they would have let's say a family
is rich mashallah the guy is wealthy
and he finds a girl usually the family
will not allow it
because to their understanding that i
know how can he get married just
14 15. you know i mean even the the talk
right now just me saying that i'm sure
that a lot of people
get shivers and their hair on their back
you know is is just like you know rising
because they cannot we've been
conditioned so much to believe that this
is ridiculous how can you say
that someone could get married at 14 or
15
right impossible how dare you talk like
that
okay all i'm telling you is that they
are biologically ready
yet they cannot do it in halal so
because there are there's a readiness
and a need
they will take one of these options that
i've listed zina
pornography homosexuality or lesbianism
or if they
somehow mashallah they fast and they
lower their gaze
inshallah there are some people like
that then they have a wet dream and then
you know that kind happens you know but
i mean
how often will they have a wet dream so
and how long do they live like this
till they get married so the average
muslim gets married today the age of 28
30 or so on so till that age
what happens right well obviously they
will take one of these options
and again i'm not talking just from my
head i'm talking from
the clients that i deal with the
statistics that i've looked at
the you know the researches that i deal
with the other counselors that i talk to
so yes the muslim one of these issues
the problem is that once you reach
marriage now 28 30 35 some real
delay till 35 you've spent pretty much
15 to 20 years of your life your best
years
where you had the strongest levels of
you know testosterone or
you know desire be it the female or the
male
um wasting it right just just skidding
just back up you know just just uh
misfiring
and now you are parachuted into a nikah
in front of a sheikh and you're expected
to know how to deal with a woman
or you know how to marry and then we
wonder why marriages fail
because there's been no preparation
before there's no
training there is no there's all this
time it's been about me
me me me me me and after 20 15 20 years
finally it's we
and then i'm like i don't know how to
act with another woman i don't know how
to deal with her i have to share now my
time i have to do this i have to listen
to her
she has to listen to me i have to worry
about her being pleased in intimacy
right because we're talking about
intimacy not not only about me
i pleasured myself for 20 years now i'm
gonna have to worry about pleasuring
someone else
and that's why a lot of couples
have that problem with intimacy because
what is the main usually main complaint
is that worship he finishes and then
i'm just left to myself right he doesn't
care about me he's not worried about my
feelings
and to for to me to be pleased from both
sides
because they're not used to it there's
no preparation
there's we don't you know so okay we we
deliver these kids they're born they're
raised they reach puberty we just leave
him leaving leave him
and all of a sudden we might have a talk
with them once in a blue moon and say
okay
now it's time for you to get married
you're 33 years old congratulations
i found you someone a lot of times in
many of the cultures the muslim cultures
there's not even a choice for the person
to marry who they like
or to be even asked there's a lot of
arranged marriages
and people are just given there and okay
survive so no within first two years
divorce
okay 52 divorce or more now
and the ones who sometimes stay together
they do it because the shame of the
family
and then there's abuse and they suffer
and people worry well they wonder why
there's abuse
why the kids don't grow up properly why
there's issues in development because
the two are not jiving together
right so we have a big problem
fundamental problem in the pre-marriage
stage
in the vetting the up
to marriage time where we are
getting to know someone how by what age
what are the priorities
we're mess i think this is a whole big
mess there's no look
ask any imam or any scholar right now or
any stand
is there a standard for the muslim ummah
it's just haphazardly up and down
depends on which culture what who does
where
there's nothing you know the same way
when we say okay guys
let's there's salah there's a fik for
salah there's a certain way we shall
align our
our lines we have to put our hands in
salah in a certain way
we have to do certain things this is
from the filk
so why not why not when it comes to
marriage
our relationship with allah is very
important but also our relationship with
each other is very important
so why do we not focus also on that why
do we not talk about that
why everyone's just left to figure it
out themselves and then we wonder
why our communities are suffering
why the marriage is suffering you know
it's it's it's a it's a big mess
so there's a lot of things that need to
be talked about
on this issue how how do you find a
woman how do you approach by which age
how do you do you have to have some
premarital counseling what kind of
questions do you ask her
can you talk to her can you discuss how
do you
tell your family if you found someone uh
how are they gonna react
there's there's just so many questions i
don't even know where to start to be
honest maybe you guys can
can pick certain things that we can
discuss about but
it's just i got so much alhamdulillah
okay so i got two things on my mind and
these are from
patrons that have asked us these
questions saying that when you do do an
intimate series
let us know so number one how do i know
i'm financially ready
for marriage this is from a man and uh
what are my like
responsibilities obligations and the
second one
um if i have had sexual experiences in
the past
do i need to disclose this even though
you know it was in my
idea i to my next spouse
okay so the first one with regards to
how do i know if i'm financially ready
subhanallah today i was teaching a
seerah class and we were
at the hijra of the prophet when the
sahaba came from mecca to medina
and abdul rahman alf he's
he's connected in brotherhood with one
of the ansars
and this guy was one of the wealthiest
men in medina
and he said i am the wealthiest guy
i'm going to give you half of my wealth
and he says i have two wives he says
look at them which one you like i'll
divorce her you can marry her after it
i mean can you imagine bro i come to
you know a brother you're a new muslim
brother you're making hijra are you
coming you know and i'm telling you bro
i have the money take half and have here
have uh you know
four wives you take two i take two you
know come on let's not be
you know one and one right you take two
i take two you know and now
i'm telling you pick the ones that you
want you you go first
right because this would happen man this
is the the hadith is very famous
just show me the market
all right so this is true
so he went to the market he bought some
butter some cheese whatever he had
and he start hustling you know he was
hustling
in the market of benue the jews
so he beat them at their game okay he
was hustler
so within a few days the prophet saw
meets him
i think a lot of times when we read this
hadith we talk about it the love between
the ansar and the muhajiri
and how this man was about to sacrifice
his wealth and his family
for his brother but we don't see one
part of the hadith
which is very important so the prophet
saws sees him wearing some nice clothes
he says
what is this he says i got married
boom what so he says the process said
how much did you give her look at it
look at the questions
look at the questions you might find
that this is wrong how how why is he
asked
how much did he give her he says a a
nugget of gold
he went from cheese and butter to
wearing nice clothes and nugget of gold
but i think what's important to know is
what was his objective for
hustling he wanted to get married man
okay because he understood what is his
priority
he needed to get a woman in halal the
guy offered it to him he could have been
easy bro
it was easy it was halal for him he
could have taken it
he says no i'll do it myself he went to
the market switched a few things around
boom boom next few days he's wearing a
nice you know
he's sporting a nice coat and the
processor said what is that
explains to him alhamdulillah prophet
happy
but look at his priority did he say
let me make some more money i got to get
to the next level
maybe i need to get a house or this or
that maybe i can wait another year
literally the hadith says within a few
days this could have been literally a
few days
because for him his objective was i need
a wife
because he understood that allah
subhanahu wa support the person who was
going to
take that leap of faith and sacrifice he
was not lazy he didn't just say like
you know i'm so poor what can i do no
he went he took the azbab as we say he
did
the hustling he hustled
and he got he got his queen that's what
he wanted
that was his objective he didn't say i
want to buy a camel
i need a ride right he didn't say that
he didn't
that's not what you saw him with he
didn't say i need to get my house
i need to get a few coats before i get
married i need to get this or that no
first thing he did is he went and got
enough money
to give her mahar and i was a good man
a good dowry and he got married
so honestly personally when i study the
seed of the process
and look at the example of the sahaba
and what they've done how they got
married
i believe that our brothers today are
cutting themselves very short
in the fact that they don't believe
themselves and they don't believe in
allah being a razak i'm not saying
i just feel that the mindset is wrong
because if you marry allah will give you
risk
if you have a child allah will give you
risk allah
you know not we will take care of you
and of them you know so i think a lot of
guys cut themselves short
because society has conditioned them to
the american dream that you gotta have
the house with the picket fence and you
gotta have the car
first you gotta get the degree first and
and then and you reach
28 30 and you've been spending 10 15
years of your life by yourself
what being celibate and then finally you
get married and then you wonder why your
marriage is failing
because you prioritized everything
before
being intimate and you know the human
being
the development of the human being is
very interesting don't think that at 30
or like the way you were when you're 16
or 17 or 18
you're not like that your mind has
changed allah
your your your thoughts your ideas your
personality
solidifying is much harder to change now
to undo things
so you're missing out those times where
you can have
a partner a woman next to you and to
grow together
to get to be together to reach your 30s
together
and to to to to love each other
and to be intimate with each other and
to go through those difficult times
together
and that's going to make a big
difference but if you're not
then you reach 30 and you're you're
suffering so i don't know the brothers
who are
really really putting finances at the
top of their charts
and delaying marriage because that i
don't agree with it i got married in my
i think it was second year of university
alhamdulillah
and you know my wife was in university
as well we were studying together
being together it was much easier
because i think i would have i'd have
died man if not i would have lost my
mind
in in you know canadian university i'm
so sorry but what happens there and the
dorms and
what was going on on the campus and how
the you know forget about
as i said in the previous episode i
think i said forget about you not going
after the girls the girl's going to come
after you
it is what it is so alhamdulillah
it was a huge thing and yes it was tough
but i was working i was doing research
whatever i was doing
and allah subhanahu wa tala provided and
you just got to find the right girl who
understands you is willing to
you know don't look for the girl who's
going to wait for you the finish line
man you got to be with the girl who's
going to be
willing to run the race with you you
know or
to to join the ride while you're making
it you know what i mean not just waiting
for you at the end once you've made it
that's when she's like hey i'm here i'm
ready now no that's not the right woman
man
that's not the right woman so yeah i
think
uh there should be no excuse there
should be no excuse whatsoever
that finances and whatnot are something
that will stop you
do your thing i don't know delay a bit
take a job part-time job whatever
and and go for it talk allah you know
and just do it but do it like abdul
rahman al he didn't stay
he went to the market and he beat the
jews at their own game
and he turned things around and he got
married so he did
he took the azbab don't just sit there
lazy
doing nothing thinking that you know
things are just going to solve
themselves no
but have that mentality man look guys
look around right now who is leading the
world
we're not leading the world who is
pushing
who is leading the discourse is the
non-muslims
5 a.m club the millionaires club this
and that
all these guys when you talk about it
the entrepreneurship mind
it's not the mind that's going to be
stuck waiting for a salary every two
weeks that's going to make the
difference in this world
trust me man you want to jump in the rat
race
sorry but it's going to be you know some
rat behavior
but that's not how the sahaba lived look
at abdul rahman he took a risk man
i believe that a lot of men who are not
willing to take a risk this is cowardice
behavior
we you know you got to take a leap of
faith sometimes you just got to do it
and that's what's going to make you a
man it's going to those mistakes you're
gonna fall down you're gonna
rise up you're gonna mess up a lot i
messed up a lot in my life man
but you know what there's only one thing
i regret in my life my sins that's it
other than that i don't regret anything
my sins i regret them yes between me and
allah
but other than that any decision i've
taken i never regret
alhamdulillah alhamdulillah no regrets
whatsoever i messed up a lot
i disappointed people i disappointed
myself i
messed up a lot but alhamdulillah man
like when i look at it right now
no regrets man no regrets
and it is what it is you know what i
mean you you embrace it like a man you
take it you own it
but you're not going to be able to
if you're going to have the mentality of
just waiting for a salary or just
waiting to finish your degree
always waiting waiting waiting waiting
excuses excuses excuses
and you find yourself late in life then
you're like oh man
i regret it you know oh man i wouldn't
have done that
i was going to say what uh university
did you go to in canada
university of windsor windsor okay you
ever met those girls that are saying uh
i want to do this i want to get this
degree then i want to
you know learn about myself and travel
the world and then
i'll think about settling down or was it
at your time it wasn't like that
uh those those girls who say these
things
are girls because they don't see
value men anymore right
so they're just looking around i don't
see anything i might as well do
something else
trust me a woman a woman when she sees a
man of value
who understands what he wants who's
decisive in his life
um she's gonna be ready bro to settle
with him because women are a bit
different you know it's
not in their fitrah to pursue
necessarily these degrees they i mean
they want to they can but it's not their
main objective
it doesn't jive with their fitrah when a
woman
sees a man who wants who knows what he
wants
she's going to definitely definitely
want to link up with him
but if she doesn't find the right man
there's no the market doesn't have any
you know proper men around no abdul
rahman in the house around
then of course she's gonna be like well
i don't see anything around might as
well take a walk in the park
you know what i mean to check out the
weather and check out the the scenery
because there's nothing around anymore
that is this is interesting
you know women bro women are if they see
a man of high value
who's strong who values himself who
knows what he wants
bro she's ready to commit i mean women
are just a bit more mature than men
already in their mindset they want that
they need that commitment
a woman it's not in her fitness to be
like yeah i want to travel
and see the world this is something
that's been indoctrinated into them
recently
through these vloggers and you know
these people traveling around now and
all over youtube
oh i want to do it as well right but if
you're going to ask her
choose between a real man that really
excites you and when you look at him
you're in awe
not like no i'm not so sure like when a
woman
sees a man of value she's like you know
like she's ready
right so of course ask her to choose
between that
the stability that connects to her fitra
and that strength that she wants that
masculinity that
the the opposite of her and going around
and
you know traveling the world and she's
gonna be like of course i want this man
you know what i mean she's not gonna
choose you know to to to
roam around the world you know
backpacking it's just not in their
fitness no it's not it's not connecting
to that
yes there are a lot of these girls doing
the youtube videos
but they're pushing us so i was just
reading uh
the other day the article of this woman
the main character from sex in the city
you guys remember that show angel you
would remember that
right of course
so and she's 45 right now you know and
you know
the main talent she said i regret not
marrying and not having a child early
you know that was the main thing i
regret it
right she says it's just such a loss
you know what i mean yes it might sound
like a nice idea at some point to go
around the world and do these things and
be successful
but in the end when when nature catches
up with you
they regret it man so yeah i think
that's the first question the second
question with regards to
disclosing your past sexual experiences
that is not correct they should not do
that what's your past is your past no
one has the right to know anything about
your past allah is forgiving your sins
and this is your past and even being a
woman or a man it doesn't matter
you should not i've seen disasters like
subhanallah i remember
one of my clients he was saying that he
was sitting around with his wife
and he loved his wife subhanallah such a
sad story
i mean and they were such a good couple
and they had children together
i think they had about uh
three or four children and he was a
convert he was a convert he was in
canada
and one night they're just sitting
around watching something or whatever on
tv
and i guess the wife just asked like you
know i think something came up
and she said something like oh so i'm
sure you are like a
you know a casanova back in the days
isn't it right
and he's like no no no no no no i said
come on
come on tell me we're not going to get
upset we're friends you know
we love each other he's like no no no
come on you're lying come i know you
were come on come on look you're so good
looking even now you know i see girls
looking at you
i'm sure you you had a few you know he's
like
you know hey come on come on tell me
tell me i'm not gonna get upset tell me
a few oh a few huh
like how many how many forget it no come
on come on please please i'm not getting
upset
i swear well i'm not gonna get upset
you know like i don't know eight
nine eight
nine bro in two days they were divorced
two days they were divorced and they
never got back together that's it they
were divorced
okay she went ballistic she was a born
muslim he was a convert she was a virgin
when he married her
and that was his mistake and i told him
bro that was your mistake bro you should
have lied through your teeth bro
you know as omar khattab was talking to
that woman and
who her husband asked her by allah do
you hate me
and she said yes i said why don't you
lie why don't you tell that you know
he said but he said by allah i don't
love him
but how many marriages are built only in
love
but the taqwa of allah so you should
have told them
whatever no you know you cannot
this is your past you cannot you don't
know how that person is going to react
right this is your past allah is
forgiving your sins
what is no one's business to know
anything about you
and what happened you know what i mean
so i
i totally advise people against that
people i know people say you should tell
you should be honest about this
bro it's like people will judge you will
hold it against you
30 years from now they'll hold it
against you
it destroyed that guy's marriage i've
seen many marriages falling apart from
this you know
i mean subhanallah guys too you know oh
come on
honey i know you had men before and this
and that
span a lot the guys do it too and then
what do they say oh was he better than
me in bed
oh come on you know and stuff like that
right yeah
like that's what guys ask you know i've
had you know uh
people ask me can i ask her this or that
i said bro no
ever ever talk about these things and
even the women say what should i say
when you ask me that
tell them you're the best i've never
seen anything in my life like you
you know that's what it is you cannot
what you're gonna say no you're not
you know it's like come on what where is
this relationship going to go from there
human beings have jealousy you got to be
careful you got to be strategic in the
way you place yourself this is the dean
this is not
it's there's a fick of information of
what you release and what you can see
and this is not nothing wrong with it
you know what i mean gabriel is like
that uncle
a real uncle bro um
i agree bro there's no point concealing
your past but that being said romney
what's your body count
[Laughter]
listen all jokes aside i agree with you
a man of value is ready for marriage and
oftentimes and there's dunya
finances so get your money right uh
people forget that
it's from the sunnah it's from islam we
are the providers we have to be the
providers and the protectors and the
provisioners
but that being said there's a difference
yes you are the provider
but i've seen too many brothers hit me
up and it's like the month of ramadan
right obviously i'm going to leave names
out of it
because i don't want to backbite but
it's ramadan
and they hit me up and they're like oh
uh oh five this girl hit me up uh
on minda minder is like this this it's
like tinder for muslims right
and i'm like okay bro one red flag
off the rip is he's on minder talking to
a girl
during ramadan okay whatever you know
maybe they want to get in the cab but it
gets deeper
and he's like uh bro she's uh she's
stuck somewhere
and she needs uh she needs me to send
her
money for gas should i
do it will a lot question me what if she
actually needs it and i'm like listen
bro
you ever see a guy so beta it's like you
can't even help him but it's like you
want to help him you can like
you want to be you know guiding him so i
tell him i'm like okay
realistically speaking what person in
the right mind drives a car
with their gas low or knowing it's going
to be low no like
the chances of that happening something
on i've been driving for six
plus years never had that bro never did
i did i go somewhere and my car just
stalled on me but
let's say it is you know she's on minder
bro she doesn't even know you you don't
know her
and she's out here like send me 200 for
gas what tank needs 200
even premium gas bro even though
lamborghini says bro
it does not you know and he's like yeah
but like you know i want to do it and
i'm you're like bro come on man like
if i didn't know you're if i didn't know
your financial situation
which was already kind of struggling and
you want to do this come on bro like
how is this how is this even a thing bro
so you have to be a provider but there's
too many guys i know
you know buying bags and nice stuff for
a girl that they like
they don't even bro she doesn't even
like you back bro you want
this president of their foundation to be
based on gifts
and materials yeah listen i don't think
he's particularly beta but it like you
gotta think he's in he's in ramadan
and if he's like a legit muslim can
y'all hear me
yeah okay my bad is so i got 10 battery
uh i i mean the picture to pop up out of
nowhere bro
but um nobody else knows what we're
talking about
if he's like a legit muslim then he's
probably thinking like ah this is sakai
this is charity
but like that's not really charitable
when this person is trying to take
advantage of you
exactly and get that money like yo my
dad and obviously i'm not gonna say too
much here but one day he hit me up he's
like man like i'm talking to all these
girls right now
and like they're all so beautiful
they're all into me but they all keep
asking me if i can help them
pay for like so-and-so and like send me
200 or 300
but i just i put my hand on my phone i'm
like bro
you serious right now
yeah you should have corrected them they
don't like you bro
i told him the truth bro i never i never
lied in my pops
he didn't like it though that being said
like
i think for women if you do want to buy
stuff for your man
gift spoiling cool but you shouldn't be
required to financially support
the household and bro you guys know it's
you and uh
uh rami how many coaching calls have we
had how many people hit us up in patreon
from uh them being you know young
supporting the whole family
you know or or kids just just being like
oh my dad doesn't work my mom doesn't
work
i'm here carrying the flag even if it
was a guy i would be like bro that's
kind of sus but if these are girls bro
it shouldn't be like this like as the
man bro how better do you look how weak
you look
at your only real obligation from allah
in a marriage as a provider you can't
even fulfill that
because you're looking for a job and
it's been a couple years what
allah is so sad man it's so sad they
don't want to settle they feel like you
know i've been
this i've had this career for this long
and just because i got laid off doesn't
mean
i shouldn't go back to that career
they're not willing to work out like a
harvey's until they get back to that
career
um just to be making something subhan
allah that eagle
it's crazy man but way too many way too
many sisters
message us with a story like that it's
actually it's kind of crazy
so sad man listen if i get into a
position like that
and i can't do what i love and i gotta
support my family like dude i'm gonna
sell my body i'm gonna be like that
that stripper that got into jannah
because i said they can't
first of all not a stripper okay okay
y'all know what i mean
y'all going to see me in jannah with no
clothes on
it was like yo what you doing like bro
you don't want to know
because a lot a lot you know and there's
that balance you know
of allah can't judge me but you know
most of the time people are saying it's
cap
they know they know that they're trying
to have an excuse be a victim
but you're right and uh i agree with uh
100 with brother gabriel
that as men you need to find that
balance between
establishing yourself as a man of value
but also
taking this step and trusting allah
fully
that even if i'm not fully where i want
to be
one i'll get a good woman who wants me
uh while i'm trying to become a champion
not waiting at the finish line because
there's this quote that uh
men chase championships women chase
champions right and you guys already
know that
so that balance between that and also
you know what even if it doesn't happen
allah will provide allah will give me a
risk
it's it's not it's from allah anyway
right just take that step
have that kid i'm not saying have kids
aimlessly when you're not ready but you
get what i mean
get married have a kid there's nothing
wrong there's no too young this whole
propaganda
or you're you're only like you're only
26. what do you mean you're only 26 bro
as a woman you got maybe three-ish
four-ish years left
if you're 26 before you know every other
chance of congenital defects in your kid
just goes up through the roof
as a man it's not the same but you know
there's no point
you know having this this fitna of not
being able to lower your gaze
walking around and not in a hyper sexual
environment
uh not having life
yeah it honestly like it
everything you're saying hits home for
myself because
like i'm a dude that's like real into my
passion my purpose like what i'm doing
where it's like
you ask these two mans right here and
they'll tell you like
i make use of my time to where i have
like maybe one hour
maybe zero free time and like i'm over
here saying to myself nah nah
i can't have a wife i can't do this i
can't do that but it's like
it's just so it's so clear it's so
evident that like
getting married really does fulfill high
for your dean because if not like
bro i'm still man i still got
testosterone out of the roof i'm still
raging over here so it's like my mind's
like going crazy
thinking about women every time i see a
girl i'm just zoned in
locked and i'm like damn
so you guys married or why i am
and uh i know it's but rami's not i am
not married actually i am married
i'm married to the game but it shouldn't
be like that though
i was going to say that come on so
father you're married
yeah how many years now uh
been a few months few months okay
so fresh on the way right
on the way on the way in sha'allah anger
what's going on
i'm the best little boy
like we were talking about before like i
i don't know i'm
i got questions that's all perfect
so i guess we we talk about the next
episode yes sir
because a lot of people are wondering
what can i do what's permissible can i
can i see a girl without her hijab
without diwali can i get to know her can
i
play 20 questions and ask what's your
body count well we already covered that
question
but there's so many things that people
don't know can i whatsapp her
uh can i you know send her a selfie
you know so many so many stuff so we'll
talk about inshallah
uh but yeah if you guys made it this far
feel free to hit like
follow brother gabriel i'll romani on
youtube links in description
and most importantly if you have any
story that you could relate to us
like something i said or how angel could
relate ramen whatever
you want to just you know let us know
your experience in life
if you could share something let us know
in the comments because
you know just like the thing that
brother gabriel said that when somebody
asked the question in class
can i watch porn with my spouse and
after that everyone stayed and everyone
could relate to that
it's like you need to be that first
thing to engage conversation sometimes
right
so a lot of people might think oh if i
say this i'll be ostracized or nobody
could relate or they'll think i'm weird
but you'll be surprised how many people
are literally thinking the exact
same thing
100
all right may allah never put on hell in
that situation he described the
situation
i mean i'll say that one more time
may allah never force you to take that
kind of career i don't want to see you
naked
it's like for the next i mean i mean
i mean i mean close it off boy all right
with that being said may allah bless you
all
right
come on
absolutely
that's i feel like those two
it gives a perfect answer bro
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm